the infamous racist NASCAR news is fake
news Jimmy Kimmel issues a
passive-aggressive apology and we
explored the best-selling book in
America on white fragility i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressive VPN you have a right to
privacy protected at expressvpn calm
slash event so indeed fake news but you
know no news is good news
here's the thing there are a bunch of
people online who are very very upset
that it turns out that bubble Wallis's
news was in fact not a news that bubble
Wallis's news was in fact just a pull
down string at the garage now listen
behind closed doors and privately i had
my doubts that this story was real from
the very very beginning but i was
hesitant to voice those doubts because
after all in the ass car which is a
major organization head back the story
yeah and nascar should know i mean they
have cameras in all of the garages you
think they have those multi-million
dollar engines over there and they don't
have cameras in the garage that cameras
and all the garages they know all of
their staffers presumably they've done
some sort of internal investigation
found that the story was legit in order
to parrot it and make it you know the
number one story in the world or
alternatively they were duped or
alternatively they are just unbelievably
full of crap and decided to go woke or
go broke and simply believe whatever
story Bubba Wallace told them so
wherever the story came from the story
was promulgated and the story now that
is being promulgated the Bubba Wallace
really didn't know what was going on
from the very beginning Bubba Wallace
was told that there was a news in his
locker and he didn't really check it out
and then he repeated this story and all
this in listen I'm willing to give
people the benefit of the doubt until
the point where they completely blow the
benefit of the doubt and at this point I
feel like NASCAR has blown the benefit
of the doubt I feel like Bubba Wallace
is blown the benefit of the doubt and
this feels a lot like everybody decided
to lump to jump to a a ridiculous
conclusion based on non evidence and
based on an obvious it based on
something that obviously was not a news
in order to promulgate a particular
narrative thing I always say a tribute
to stupidity virtually everything in
malice virtually nothing I'm having a
real hard time on this one I'm having a
real hard time not attributing to malice
what happened here because again
NASCAR has cameras there I mean I
tweeted out about this because NASCAR
had said that it happened and NASCAR
should you know release the footage and
then prosecute whoever did it
maybe the person should be prosecuted
well last cart must have known all along
that it turns out that the noose was not
in fact a noose
it was the pull string on a garage it
was the put that had been there for a
year before this I mean could NASCAR
have been this ignorance could Bubba
Wallace have been this ignorant that he
was just trips him through the daisies
here basically singing the song that
that NASCAR had written for him or is it
possible that Bubba Wallace kind of knew
that this was BS all along and decided
to exaggerate it so again I'm willing to
grant people the benefit of the doubt I
was willing to grant NASCAR the benefit
of the doubt until they lost the benefit
of the doubt and even last night after
this story came out I was willing to
grant Bubba Wallace the benefit of the
doubt that he was told by NASCAR there
was a noose in his locker and then he or
in his garage and then he saw a picture
and kind of like a news and he was like
well if NASCAR says that that's the case
then probably that's the case and that's
that's really upsetting and then Bubba
Wallace went on national TV and decided
that he was gonna double down on this
after the FBI investigation and at that
point you know what his sincerity is in
question at that point I have to think
to myself well maybe he knew all along
this wasn't really what it appeared to
be and he decided to go along with it
anyway so here was the statement the
NASCAR released last night that they
released it quietly and first of all
this came after people online right the
online researchers did some very easy
research where they showed pictures of
the garages last year and what they
showed is drawstrings
on the garage right the pull strings on
the garage door and we're shaped like a
hand basically a hand hold right they
were they were not really looking like a
new so much as you know a drawstring
that you pulled down on a garage like
everyone has in their garage in America
like that Wood Brothers racing group put
up a statement and we are thankful there
was no one involved in perpetrating hate
during this week's race just like the
rest of the NASCAR garage we were
shocked and appalled to learn of the
existence of the Rope fashioned like a
noose one of our employees alerted us
yesterday morning it without knowing the
details of the incident he recalled
seeing a tied handle in the garage pull
down rope from last fall we immediately
alerted NASCAR and have assisted the
investigation in every way possible what
transpired over the past day is he plus
is a unit that is only served to
strengthen the bonds between each and
every crew member fan and on fan alike
the wood or brother's organization is
proud to stand with Bubba Wallace and
the entire industry as we work to make
every race fan a part of our NASCAR
family
okay now that would all be well and good
if NASCAR had waited to jump to this
conclusion and then spread
as the number one news story in America
and proclaim that this was indicative of
broad and deep American racism I pointed
out yesterday by the way that even if
there had been a news in the garage the
fact that every single driver and pit
crew in NASCAR marched with Bubba
Wallace to the front of Talladega Motor
Speedway it was a pretty good indicator
that the person who did it was an
outlier now it turns out the entire
thing was bullcrap from beginning to end
and now we're supposed to believe this
is a unifying incident as opposed to um
guys somebody did something wrong here
here's what NASCAR said the FBI has
completed its investigation in Talladega
Superspeedway and determined that Bubba
Wallace was not the target of a hate
crime the FBI report concludes and
photographic evidence confirms that the
garage-door pull rope fashioned like a
news had been positioned there since as
early as last fall this was obviously
well before the 43 teams arrival and
garage assignment we appreciate the
FBI's quick and thorough investigation
and are thankful to learn that this was
not an intentional racist act against
Bubba we remain steadfast in our
commitment to providing a welcoming and
inclusive environment an inclusive
environment for all who love racing okay
and that should be by the way the normal
reactions they should be oh that's good
that there wasn't a racist incident in
NASCAR I mean the guy just called for a
massive change in NASCAR just went along
with it as far as confederate flags it's
kind of good to know that there wasn't a
massive racist incident but it seems
that there are many people who are very
disappointed today namely people who are
looking for a supply of racism that is
actually a little bit short for what
they are looking for at this point I've
said before that the demand for racist
incidents in order to promulgate the
narrative that Americans deeply racist
and covered with racism Stemmons to
stern the demand for that much racism is
not met by the supply of racism well if
it were met by the supply of races and
you wouldn't have to manufacture
incidents like this one international
stories or cling to the story once it
had been completely debunked and yet
there are people who are completely
clinging to the story after it is
debunked so let us just remember let's
take a trip down memory lane over the
last 72 hours Bubba Wallace went on
national TV yesterday this is yesterday
morning and he said this was a
despicable act of racism and then
suggested that anyone who doubted the
story was a racist so if you doubted the
story you were racist no I didn't
express doubt about it again because now
at least not publicly because again
NASCAR had basically put out a statement
I figure okay NASCAR is a major
organization with internal deliberative
bodies and and and they're a massive
corporation they probably had done an
investigation they probably couldn't be
this stupid well it turns
wrong I was wrong I was but you can ask
my producer Colton behind closed doors I
was a little skeptical that this thing
was actually a news placed in Bob
Wallace's garage the reason I was
skeptical is not because I don't think
there are bad people who are racists out
there it's because we've seen probably
in my lifetime yeah in the last 5-10
years alone probably a dozen cases of
people claiming that a noose was left as
a racist symbol and all of them so far
as I'm aware turned out to be bullcrap
we had one in the last two weeks right
we had one in Oakland where a black guy
put up some ropes on a tree so that
people could use them for exercise and
the Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf then
launched a hate crime investigation
suggesting that the insert the the
intent of the ropes didn't matter only
the impact of the ropes matter and she
was going to investigate it anyway even
though a black guy had put up things
they didn't look at anything like
nuisance so whenever I hear a news story
my first reaction is well maybe we
should wait for you know all the
evidence to come out unless a giant
major organization backs the story well
now I'm just gonna go with okay I'm just
gonna do it no matter whether a giant
organization that's the story or not
anyway Wallace went on national TV and
not only did he say this was a
despicable act of racism he said anyone
calling it a hoax is a racist if you
even had doubts you were racist people
are entitled to their own opinion to
make them feel good whatever make them
help them sleep at night it's just it's
just unfortunate circumstances and in a
in a terrible time that we're in right
now you're 2020 will be one year - for
sure forget moving forward but you know
it's it's it's simple-minded people like
that the ones that are afraid of change
they they use everything in their power
to defend what they stand up for and
instead of trying to listen and
understand what's going on
simple-minded people afraid of change
those are the people who are who are
doubting the story about the news in the
in the garage and then he suggested than
anyone who called it a hoax or staged
was a racist and if you said that it was
a hoax or a stage and you were also a
racist as well so good stuff here from
Bob Wallace this was all before the
report came out and again I was willing
to grant him the benefit of the doubt
even here right I was willing to go
along with this okay well maybe he
didn't know I mean at the time had been
told by NASCAR presumably there was a
noose in his garage so you know maybe he
believed the same thing that I believe
maybe and then you had people like Jamel
Hill right Jamel Hill who is
declared all of American society root to
branch racist everything is racist
Jamela Hill she said yesterday that the
news was a reminder of who the sport was
for not the giant numbers of people
drivers and and Pitts members who are
walking with Bubba Wallace the news was
the reminder of who the sport was for us
head Jamel Hill yesterday
NASCAR they've had to deal with maybe
not directly nooses installs but the
shadow of the Confederate flag being
considered a symbol that you often saw
at NASCAR races these very overt
reminders about who this sport is
exactly for and who should be a fan of
this sport this is something that
they've been dealing with a long time
and unfortunately in this way these
issues bubble to the surface in this way
they bubble to the surface they just do
that right now as I mentioned on the
show the the way that we do
conversations in this country is maybe
the dumbest way to do conversations ever
which is we wait for a flashpoint
incident and then we attribute it to a
broader system right is what the Left
likes to do they wait for a flashpoint
incident then they tribute to a broader
system so instead of citing statistics
or disparities that are based on on
things that are not behaviorally
explainable instead what they will do is
they will say newson Bubba Wallace is
garage
this means all NASCAR fans are racist
right which is just insane even if there
was a news in Bubba Wallace his garage
which there was not then that would not
mean that all NASCAR fans are racist but
that's who jemelle Hill is and this is
the way that she promotes her message
now as it turns out we have pictures of
it the the old drawstrings here was
pretty obvious from anybody who had seen
this thing I mean as soon as I saw these
pictures online last night I was like oh
yeah that's a pretty credible
explanation because literally people had
uncovered photos from last year showing
the picture of the drawstring on the
garage door from last year it had the
the hands high in it right that looks
basically like a loop was just a hand
loop and then they showed the picture
the next year and the hand look was
missing there's a shorter rope so it
looked as though it had been cut Hey no
again I was willing to grant Bubba
Wallace the benefit of the doubt here
right you can see in that picture there
is the there is the hand hold in the in
the rope and then the very next year is
just going on because somebody to cut it
off for whatever reason okay before
Bubba Wallace got there long before
Bubba Wallace got there okay so as well
to grant everybody the benefit of the
doubt everybody was acting in good faith
and had a good intention then Bubba
Wallace went on zongman show last night
and Bubba Wallace on Don lemons show
decided to not only stick with the story
but to double down on the story after
the release of the NASCAR statement on
the FBI report so Bubba Wallace said no
no no it's a straight up news straight
up a noose no it isn't the FBI deployed
15 agents 15 to investigate this 15
agents so as my colleague Matt Walsh has
pointed out we've got protesters tearing
down federally put up statues all over
the United States nobody's doing
anything about it
a guy supposedly finds a noose in his
garage and we deployed fifteen FBI
agents to investigate it clearly we're
not taking racism seriously enough in
this country then then efforts to bunks
Bubba Wallace goes out there he's like
no no I'm not taking the debunking it's
a straight-up news now this makes me
wonder whether Bubba Wallace knew all
along it wasn't the news because up
until now I was willing to grant him the
credibility of sincerity right that he
sincerely believed that this thing was a
racist symbol but once it comes out it's
not instead of being relieved like oh
good that's great like I'm not the
victim of racism it was all
misinterpreted instead of that he's like
no no it definitely was racism I have
very little sympathy for this at this
point okay I will admit to you and my
sympathy my sympathy levels have dropped
below zero at this point as somebody who
has been victimized by an awful lot of
people saying extraordinarily honest
emetic things I was the number one
target of anti-semitism in the United
States online in 2016 I received death
threats in the mail all sorts of good
wonderful stuff I remember a specific
incident okay there's an incident where
somebody sent a piece of mail directly
to my house and now my house is not
registered online or anything and so
this was weird right when people send
mail directly to my house I'm a little
suspicious and I like an idiot decided
to open this piece of mail I open the
piece of mail and in the in the mail is
a is a folded up paper towel basically
and folded up paper towel I open it a
little bit and looks like there's powder
inside and I think myself oh good
somebody is that somebody sending powder
to my house like that's probably not a
good thing so I call my security people
my security people check it out they
coordinate with the police they look at
it and they decide that it actually is
not in fact a dangerous substance
there's a note that comes along that
explains what this stuff is it's not
dangerous my immediate reaction was oh
good it's not somebody trying to
my family that's a good thing right I
don't go around claiming oh this was
another anti-semitic incident against me
your normal human reaction when you find
out you are not a victim of a hate crime
is relief you're a normal human reaction
when you find out that somebody is not
targeting you for destruction and hatred
is oh good well that makes my life
easier that's nice I'm glad I'm glad by
the way even when I was receiving all of
that hate mail I never attributed it to
the entire country
it's insane okay but I certainly didn't
go on national TV and then maintain that
the thing was a piece of hate mail after
I knew it was not and yet that's exactly
what Bubba Wallace did last night I'll
show you the tape because it's truly
truly incredible I'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that it can be very
discouraging to see the same hefty cell
phone bill every single month I mean
that's a lot of money that you're
spending on your cell phone belt and
since he can't see friends and family as
much as you were going to this season
that means you're spending it off a lot
more on your cell phone bill by
switching to pure talk USA you can cut
costs and free up cash on a monthly
basis starting with your wireless
provider pure talk covers 99% of
Americans the president and CEO of pure
talk is a u.s. veteran who cares deeply
about serving Americans by making
wireless affordable start your saving
today it would be irresponsible frankly
not to save money when you have the
opportunity to do so and when it's this
easy right now you're paying for a lot
of data that you're not using and this
is why you ought to grab pure talk USA
instead numbers 99% of Americans and the
coverage is just as good as any of the
major cell phone companies now pound 250
say key word bed in Shapiro for
unlimited talk unlimited text two gigs
of data for just 20 bucks a month plus
you'll get 50% off your first month
right now stop paying too much to big
wireless providers switch to pure talk
today and save 50% off your first month
dial palin 250 and say the key word ben
shapiro
pure talk USA it's simply smarter
Wireless go check them out right now as
I say my sympathy quotient for Bubba
Wallace is gone like - some of these
governments go on because he won on time
and last night after the FBI
investigation found this was not a news
and proceeded to double down on it and
explain and it was in fact a news here
was Bubba Wallace last night on Tom
lemon but from the evidence that we have
that I have it's a straight up news the
FBI has stated it was a news over and
over again NASCAR leadership has stated
it was a news I can confirm that I
actually got evidence of
was hanging in my garage over my car
around my picture guys to confirm that
it was a noose and never seen anything
like it
never seen anything like it never about
last year when it was on the garage I
understand that that you weren't there
because I guess those four all-stars and
maybe both walls wasn't an all-star but
like it was their guys I mean we have
pictures of it it was a straight up news
straight up news oh my gosh you know I'm
gonna look around my desk right now oh
my oh my god what is this right here is
it my computer corridor is it a straight
up news who knows it could be anything
hey what an FBI investigation must clear
me of holding up a noose to myself oh no
that's just my computer doesn't matter
straight up news straight up just
straight up news hey by the way it's
that's just Bubba Wallace who's
maintaining this again the desire for
the story to be real is the part that's
really telling you the the deep abiding
desire on the part of many people to
make the story real is indicative again
of a desire to paint America in a
particular way as I've said where I
supposedly victimized by an anti-semitic
incident then I found out it was not in
fact an anti-semitic incident I'd be
like great good news America
good news me great good stuff instead
it's like no no I've been told by the
FBI it wasn't a news it was a news man
straight up it was a news straight up oh
my god what's this right here on my shoe
what could it be I don't know I need to
check guys hold on what what could hate
like get over yourselves get over
yourselves people okay when it's not a
noose that is the good news no news is
good news guys okay but Jamel Hill is
still mean I'm sorry it's an absurdity
it's a it's a damned absurdity and it's
horrible for the country you're not
maintaining that a racial incident
happened when it didn't happen when it
didn't happen and you're maintaining it
and you're pretending that it's good for
the country that you're maintaining it
al Sharpton went on national TV this
morning on MSNBC and he said this quote
it's clear what a noose represents did
someone know it was in the stall when
they did belatedly assigned Bubba there
I do not think we've seen closure in
this particular inquiry that's it that's
what here's what else Repton had to say
so I don't think this answers a lot of
questions and clearly from what we just
saw above a Wallis that does not seem he
who is the victim and possible target in
this matter seems to be satisfied with
this I do not think that we've seen
closure in this particular inquiry I
definitely by the way believe what el
Sharpton has to sell me on
investigations I definitely think I need
the word of Al Sharpton that an event
actually happened before I go any
further because when I think of credible
sources on criminal investigations I
think about the guy who faked a rape of
a of a young girl in the 1980s and
blamed a white DA for it and ruined his
life I definitely believe al Sharpton
when it comes to this kind of stuff I'm
sorry that all sympathy has been lost
gone gone it is it is away oh it has
been dissipated my sympathy levels are
now zero you're maintaining the story
past the point when the story can be
maintained and Jamel Hill by the way you
know what her response to this was Jamel
Hill tweeted out it was a news they just
don't believe it was directed about the
Wallace hmm what no that's not how any
of this works
that is not how any of this works it's
not a racist symbol if it wasn't
directed at Bubba Wallace and it wasn't
the news it was a hand tie on a garage
we haven't reached Pete's stupid yet no
we have not reached peak stupid because
again and there we will never reach peak
stupid
it's like Zeno's paradox the closer we
get to peak stupid the further away it
still seems and she knows paradox is the
idea if you keep having the distance
between yourself and a goal you'll never
reach the goal because you can always
divide by half okay that is it that is
what we have done at this point we are
we will never reach peak stupid we'll
just keep subdividing my Herod's breath
and move forward incrementally toward
Peaks stupid but we'll never reach peak
stupid big stupid is always a receding
goal in the distance and peak ugliness
because this is ugly ugly crap it's ugly
crap and you know what it really does it
makes people feel good in tearing down a
system they have no right to tear down
guess what
NASCAR's infrastructure is not racist
guess what NASCAR's fan base is not
racist it is not a racist fanbase and
for you to simply suggest that it's a
racist fanbase because you think that
all southerners are snaggletooth
bumpkins
who hate black people is absurd it's
absurd and demonstrates your own bias
this whole thing is ridiculous and again
the the pure unbridled evidence is you
maintain a story like this after the
story is over and we can all see your
motivation we can all see it at this
point I was willing to grant sincerity I
was willing to even grant mistake but
once you start maintaining the
credibility of a story once the story
has been completely debunked by the FBI
I don't think you're sincere anymore I
just think that you're pushing a
narrative on the back of crap that's
what I think and I think mainly you're
doing it to make yourself feel good I
think that's mainly what's going on here
and the alacrity with what with which
white progressives have glommed onto
this kind of stuff is truly incredible
it really is amazing I want to talk here
about you know not the Jamel Hills
and/or the Al Sharpton's where people
who make a living off of polarizing
people on race I don't talk about why so
many people go along with this because I
think it really is kind of important
it's kind of important basically a cult
has been formed among progressive white
woke people and that cult is that the
standards for declaring somebody races
have changed and they will continue to
change and you will be made to bow
before the mob and that's incredibly
dangerous for the country we're watching
that happen all over the country right
now we'll get to that in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact that
right now you may be putting on the Pens
that make 15 a lot of people been
talking about you're putting on the Pens
that make 15 because you're sitting at
home you can't go to the gym anymore and
supressing you're stuck in your house
it's just sitting on the couch listening
to the show and munching on the munching
on the Lay's potato chips well getting
in shape does not have to be about
losing a specific amount of weight or a
magic number on the scale it's about
building healthier habits here's the
thing you can't lose all of the weight
in one day and you can't get healthier
Justin one day you have to change your
entire system of habits and this means
that you should be using new I've been
using noumic myself as you can see I'm
spelt and lean and gorgeous and that is
because I've been using at noon so have
my parents Newman's a great way of
changing your habits it's a habit
changing solution it helps users learn
to develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses based in
psychology norm will teach you why you
do the things you do and empower you
with the tools you need to break bad
habits and replace them with better ones
Newman doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you how to
look inside your own mind and make
better decisions for yourself chat with
your goal specialist a new community to
get and help give and give help to
people going through the exact same
things you don't have to change
one day all in one day small steps make
a big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon that's a no Emma comets
appear Oh again new Montcalm / appear to
start their trial today again what do
you have to lose visit Noom calm and
slash up heroes start your trial today
that's N oom calm / Shapiro and oom calm
/ appear to sign up for your trial today
hey so meanwhile we've seen the white
progressives leading the way in all of
this right declaring their fealty to the
to the woke cause and as I've been
suggesting for weeks at this point what
started off as perhaps a good-hearted
quest to curb a police brutality has now
morphed into basically race baiters
taking advantage and white woke people
feeling good about themselves and that
is how you end up with video like this
and there's a lot of video like this so
yesterday in Washington DC
white women yelling at black police
officers I mean this is again fairly
typical unfortunately of a lot of these
protests this is white women yelling at
black police officers always good luck
you're white and you're telling this to
two black police officers you see the
problem with that a little bit oh no I
don't because you know what don't
because I'm white and I have an
experience racism myself racism is her
problem she needs to fix it that's those
paternalistic statement I've ever heard
in my entire life racism is her problem
just cuz I haven't experienced racism
and just I don't know anything about
racism that doesn't mean that I can't
yell at these black cops about racism is
the most self-centered arrogant nonsense
I've ever seen and again this is this is
breaking out across the country white
women screaming at White House officers
this is something that happened
yesterday straight from their yoga class
these these Karen's yelling at yelling
at black police officers I want to see
the manager where's the vadik here they
are
nothing gets dialog done quite like
screaming at police officers man these
these white women definitely are very
upset that they cannot buy the Lululemon
pants at the proper prices so that is
they need to speak to somebody
immediately immediately if this sounds
absurd it's because it is absurd I'm
sorry the we've now reached the point
where the parody has moved beyond the
parody
you cannot do parody of this anymore we
forgot to say come in and set up their
own independent state in Seattle like I
think we've moved beyond the parody but
just when you think we've moved beyond
the parody you realize we have not moved
beyond the parody it turns out that
there's an organized attempt to tomorrow
tear down the Emancipation Monument in
Washington DC
a monument established and paid for by
freed slaves and at the dedication of
which Frederick Douglass spoke the crowd
is now ensuring this they're sitting
Congress people who are cheering
bringing down the Emancipation Monument
in Washington DC which is a monument of
Abraham Lincoln and he is standing sort
of over and with his hand out to a freed
black slave it was recently turned the
monument to face a black educator so it
shows Lincoln paying deference to a
black educator now in terms of proximity
to other monuments and they're talking
about bringing that down so that's
exciting stuff also in Wisconsin a group
of protesters again largely white have
decided that it was necessary to pull
down a series of Capitol Hill statues
according to the the Journal Sentinel
online the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel
fury exploded outside the Wisconsin
State Capitol on Tuesday night as
protesters smashed windows at the
Statehouse attacked a state senator and
tore down two iconic statues including
one of an abolitionist who died trying
to end slavery during the Civil War the
unrest began earlier Tuesday following
the arrest of a black man who was
arrested after bringing a megaphone and
a baseball bat into a Capitol Square
struct and followed weeks of mostly
peaceful protests of the death of George
Flint okay mostly peaceful protests is
like it's just the greatest euphemism in
history it's the greatest euphemism
mostly peaceful protests they shut down
the entire city of Los Angeles at 6 p.m.
for a week because of mostly peaceful
protests okay if I spend 23 hours and 59
minutes of my day being mostly peaceful
and then I abused my child that was not
a mostly
peaceful day guys that was a day in
which I did something bad
ok that's it that's a day in which I
deserve to go to jail if I protest all
day and then I walk into a Capitol
Square restaurant carrying a baseball
bat and apparently threatening people
that was not a mostly peaceful day gang
during the melee late on Tuesday
democratic state senator Tim carpenter
he's a Democrat was assaulted after
taking a photo of protesters he said I
don't know what happened all I did was
stop and take a picture
the next thing I'm getting five six
punches getting kicked in the head
protesters chanting for the release of
the man had been arrested earlier also
broke glass at the tommy Thompson Center
on West Washington Avenue smashed
windows and lights at the State Capitol
and set a small fire at the Dane County
Jail
before police arrived just before 1:00
a.m. in Madison statues of the Wisconsin
motto forward which by the way is it's a
progressive statue who's a statue that
was erected originally in order to pay
homage to the broadening of voting
rights in the state of Wisconsin it was
commissioned by Wisconsin women and
sculpted by a Wisconsin women and
designed explicitly as a symbol of
progressivism in the first state to
ratify the 19th amendment allowing women
the right to vote okay and they ripped
that they ripped it down they ripped it
down in Madison
they also ripped down a monument of
colonel hans christian hague who's an
anti-slavery activist who fought and
died for the union during the u.s Civil
War his 100 year-old sculpture was
decapitated and thrown into a Madison
Lake by the protesters unbelievable I
mean it's just it's ridiculous and
insane how governor Tony Evers Democrat
and not intervene in this is just it
does say everything it does say
everything so well done everybody just
all good stuff meanwhile over in Oregon
again this is all yeah some of this is
is black Americans like what in terms of
the protests the the constituency of the
protests at this point at least many of
the process that are out of control are
not black Americans there are some black
Americans among the crowd largely this
is white Americans I mean look at the
pictures you can see that it's mostly
white Americans who are doing this sort
of stuff at this point and it's like
these will college students who are off
on break because of Kovan 19 and they've
decided to get active and prove to
everybody how non racist they are they
all read right fragility by Robin
D'Angelo I've decided to interrupt the
system I'll explain what exactly all
that bullcrap means in just a few
minutes here but I'm not done with my
rundown on the
meltdown of the whitewall progressive
laughs it's incredible I mean it truly
is we'll get to more of it in just one
second first you know we all have dreams
we do like some of us want to dream
about having a country where people are
not tearing down every statue in sight
some of us just want to dream about a
time we can go outside to a restaurant
but the big dreams those are kind of
hard to talk about it those are all
small dreams the big dreams those are
those are hard to talk about like if we
say them out loud well maybe they won't
come true when it comes to your future
you do have to dream big the bigger the
better and the dream of a better
tomorrow does start with better
education and that means getting a
degree from Ashford University Ashford
University's online bachelor's and
master's degree programs allow you to
learn on a convenient and flexible
schedule at Ashford expert faculty
teaches you real-world skills from real
world experience in online classes built
for life's twists and turns you can
learn from home or wherever you feel
comfortable you can pursue a degree in
one of Ashford 60-plus programs like
Business Administration Healthcare
Administration and psychology with 24/7
access to your classroom daily support
and financial aid available Ashford will
give you the tools you need to help make
it your dreams a reality so dare to
dream big your tomorrow does start today
at Ashford University there is no fee to
apply or standardized testing required
to enroll head on over to Ashford dot
edu slash Ben that is Ashford dot edu
slash Ben a sh F Ord edu slash Ben
Ashford dot edu slash Ben not all
programs available in all states ok so
we are watching the simultaneous
destruction of America's common history
our philosophy of equal rights before
law and our culture that suggests that
rights are paramount I talked about all
this in my new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps no I'm not a
prophet I just looked at what was going
on in December January and figured this
is probably going to happen and then it
did in fact happen you can go check out
that book that's available on pre-order
over at Amazon and anywhere else books
are sold how to destroy America in three
easy steps but the destruction of
America does in fact continue a pace
it's not just the Wisconsin Statutes
coming down or the attempt to take down
the Emancipation Monument everybody is
now being forced to bow before the mob
so we have Jimmy Kimmel who's now being
forced to bow before the mob which is
exciting stuff
I do love the passive-aggressive mob a
bowing of Jimmy Kimmel so Jimmy Kimmel
dressed up in blackface asked Karl
Malone for several sketches for the man
show in the early 2000s now I've long
maintained unlike other hypocrites I've
long maintained
that if you dressed up as a particular
person that is not the same thing as
dressing up as a stereotypical blackface
person in 1920 designed to mock all
black people so I don't put Jimmy Kimmel
in the same category as people who are
doing this in 1920 and I never have I've
always thought that was an absurd
comparison you know who else has thought
that Juan Williams who said so on my
show and as does everybody who has a
shred of rationality understands that
there are gradations of bad here okay
but Jimmy Kimmel was cancelled yesterday
or they tried to cancel him but here's
the problem Jimmy Kimmel has canceled
others right he spends his entire career
on late-night basically declaring and if
you're not if you're not properly woke
you should be canceled you should lose
your job you should have your life run
well now Jimmy Kimmel wants to both
maintain his moral authority and also
apologize for having done this horribly
supposedly racist thing back in the
early 2000s also on k-rock radio in the
mid 1990s he did a rap album where he
haven't hated Snoop Dogg and dropped the
n-word a bunch of times now if that
happened to a right winger Jimmy Kimmel
would be out there calling for that
person's head Oh Jimmy Kimmel doesn't
want to lose his head so instead he says
listen I'm woke so leave me alone here
was the statement Jimmy Kimmel put out
I've long been reluctant to address this
as I knew doing so would be celebrated
as a victory by those who equate
apologies with weakness and sure for
leaders who used prejudice to divide us
that delay wasn't mistakes he's gonna
blame his lack of an apology on
everybody else it's everybody else's
fault guys it's the right-wingers it's
the right-wingers I didn't want to give
them what they wanted and so I'm but I'm
going to anyway I'm gonna give them what
they wanted because that's just how big
a man I am there's those
passive-aggressive bullcrap ever he's on
k-rock radio in the mid 90s I did a
recurring impression of the NBA player
Karl Malone in the late nineties I
continued impersonating Malone on TV
we hired makeup artist to make me look
as much like Malone as possible I never
considered that this might be seen as
anything other than an imitation of a
fellow human being one that had done no
that had no more to do with Karl skin
color than it did his bulging muscles
and bald head I've done dozens of
impressions of famous people including
Snoop Dogg Oprah Eminem's ik fight al
rosey and many others in each case I
thought of them as impersonations of
celebrities and nothing more because
that's what they were obviously but he
has to buy into the new oak standard and
so he must prostrate himself before the
mob instead of just saying listen I was
imitating a celebrity get over it
instead of doing that it's no no I want
the Walkman I root for the wolf mob that
is now calling for my head i root for
them I want them to continue their
righteous work on behalf of social
justice I believe I have
evolved and matured over the last 20
plus years that says Jimmy Kimmel I hope
it is evident to anyone who watches my
show I know this will not be the last I
hear of this and then it will be used
again to try to quiet me oh we used to
try to quiet you will it ah ha so he
likes to bully everybody else but he's
afraid that he will be bullied into
silence he says I love this country too
much to allow that I won't be bullied
into silence by those who feign outrage
to advance their oppressive and
genuinely racist agendas so in other
words I did a bad thing it's everybody
else's fault and if you say that I
should be held to the same standard to
which I hold everybody else I say no I
will not be held to that same standard
you can't silence me
I can only silence everybody else I can
only silence everybody else that is not
an apology by the way that is Jimmy
Kimmel passive-aggressively attacking
everybody he doesn't like and then
pretending to apologize in the process
of course but reestablish means moral
authority because he has internalized
his has internalized his sin and you'll
be forced to internalize your saying you
will you'll be forced to internalize
your sin or you shall pay the price you
shall pay the price the white woke left
making the country worse one story at a
time I have a couple more white wolf
stories and then I want to explore for
just a second where all this bull crap
is coming from where this is coming and
it is it's coming from such a place of
arrogance and self-centeredness such a
place of paternalism the idea that black
Americans do not have agency and so they
need white woke people to save them any
white white I mean these people have a
white Savior complex beyond belief right
they need Jimmy Kimmel out there on the
front line speaking on behalf of black
people and if they don't have Jimmy
Kimmel well no one else can felt I got
like here you want to know how
ridiculous this is if they got rid of
Jimmy Kimmel tomorrow in the other place
Jimmy come with a black guy saying all
the same woke stuff would that be a
victory for social justice according to
social justice warriors it would right
because presumably late night would now
be more diverse is Jimmy Kimmel giving
up his job to a black person who can
mirror the same messages but also can
claim to have experienced racism which
Jimmy Kimmel never has of course he's
not gonna do that his voice is just too
important you see his voice is just too
important white were leftist are just
too important to give up their positions
of power in America because it is white
people's problem see here's the thing
when you make a racism white people's
problem what you are really doing is
suggesting that only white people have
the solution which is to say only white
people should have the power to change
the system
which is to say the black people don't
have the power to change the system and
black people don't have agencies in
their own lives right that is that is
the argument that is being made by the
white walk left it is the most self
flattering self aggrandizing argument
ever ever and it also leads to
paternalistic garbage policy as we will
see in just one second but first let's
talk about the fact that companies and
businesses they're under a lot of stress
right now as they begin to reopen but
many of them are looking to hire like
right now and there are a lot of people
who are out of work right now good news
zip recruiter exists to help just these
people also to help businesses like mine
get rid of the employees who want to be
gotten rid of and to replace them with
better employees I'm not gonna mention
any particular names I can mention any
particular names quote hiring can be
difficult but if you're a company that's
currently trying to hire you face new
difficulties from safely reopening your
doors to finding the right person for a
specialized role housing wire could
relate they needed an ambitious reporter
to cover news stories on the US mortgage
and housing market so they did what
everyone should do they turned a zip
recruiter zip recruiters smart matching
technology finds people with the right
experience for your job in fact four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day which is hell housing
wire found Alexandra Roja Alexandra
never imagined she could get a reporter
job in the midst of koban 19 because
hiring was frozen and the idea of
looking for a job was discouraging so
she created a profile on zip recruiter
and zip recruiter then matched Alexandra
to housing wires reporter job zip
recruiter helped Alexandra find the
right job and they can help you find the
right employee see how zip recruiter can
help you hire try it right now for free
at zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
that is zip recruiter comm slash daily
where we use daily daily wire use the
zip recruiter ourselves obviously when
we are seeking to fill positions go
check them out right now zip recruiter
comm slash it daily wire to get started
okay in just a second we are going to
get to the rest of the white wokes left
woke left bad policy and the cultish
attempts to purge the white wolf left of
all of all of the unbelievers and then I
want to talk a little bit about the
route ideology of this and where it is
coming from best expressed in Robin
D'Angelo's
garbage book white fragility which is
topping all of the bestseller lists his
crazy cult leader I mean she really is
she sounds like a Scientologist frankly
I mean she's cleansing you of your
racist thetans we're gonna get to that
in just a moment first even through app
enzymic daily wire continues to grow and
we are looking for talented passionate
people to join our team we do have
several open positions right now so if
you ever saw it to work
for this show because we have positions
open in production and marketing roles
head on over to daily wire.com slash
careers to apply and then be abused by
me and the new zip recruiter ad if
you're not already a daily wire member
you should consider getting a reader's
pass to daily wear calm it's a great
value for only three bucks a month when
you sign up get that first month for
only 99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app articles had free access to
exclusive editorials like this one Drew
has a brand new satire Andrew Clavin
roger goodell wants to include colin
kaepernick and his plans to transform
the NFL into a distant memory also I
have a brand new column out today on the
facts that the only good people who have
ever lived live today it's very very
exciting stuffs if you wanna read about
all of that you need a readers pass they
even checked out the readers past
already go to daily wear not comment
sign up for just a buck just one dollar
go check it out right now at daily
wire.com you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so other white woke stores
this ends with bad policy aims at
purchasing bad policy and ends with a
couple of things a completely divided
country which obviously we're seeing and
also purges and also bad policy because
all you have to do is claim that
somebody is racist and not in line with
you mob thinking and then all of the all
of the nuance goes away and the person
can simply be purged from polite society
there's an amazing story out by jonathan
chait over at new york magazine today
called an elite progressive listserve
melts down over a bogus racism charge on
May 28th progressive election data
analyst David short tweeted about a new
paper by Princeton professor Omar Wausau
showing that peaceful civil rights
protests moved public opinion toward
protesters while violent protests had
the opposite effect the tweet violated a
taboo in some left-wing quarters against
criticizing violent protests and led
within days to his firing what happened
after that was even more bizarre On June
11th says Jonathan Chait I wrote an
article briefly describing shorts tweet
and firing four days later progress
files a listserv for left-of-centre data
analysts kicked shor off in a message to
the group moderators described his tweet
as racist and further accused him of
having encouraged harassment of another
member of the list the racist tweet
simply summarized the findings of the
study which said that if you violently
protest it shifts people away from your
cause well if you peacefully protest it
tends to shift people toward your clause
which is number one perfectly obvious
and number two backed by data Jonathan
Chait says I've obtained the entire
thread I'm omitting the names of
contributors because they had an
expectation of privacy when they
contributed to it and their identities
aren't terribly relevant it reveals
first a cruel attempt to destroy the
professional reputation of Shore by
smearing him with unsubstantiated
charges in front of his professional
peers second it suggests an unsettling
fear of open inquiry within the
left-of-center professional data world
progress files has 1,000 members only a
tiny percentage of whom participated in
the discussion about Shore many more of
whom received a chilling message from
his expulsion more important the debate
offers a case study in the norms of
discussing race and gender within the
progressive universe many progressives
have sidestepped the problem presented
by the liberal ISM of these norms
dismissing them as goofy campus
pratfalls over the past few years and
especially in the past few weeks these
norms are gaining a foothold in elite
professional settings codified by tomes
like white fragility in too tightly
circumscribed scripts of accusation and
confession correct
I wrapped so people are getting kicked
off with
serves for citing data now I'm glad to
see that honestly I honest to god I'm
getting notes from people who are
extremely liberal we disagree with me
I'm friends with them they disagree with
me on everything political and they're
saying I'm scared out of my wits at the
censorious at the censorious cultish
culture that is being promulgated in our
newsrooms online in our journalistic
establishment it is this is it's it's
cult-like behavior it's caught like
behavior and results by the way this
call it behavior in ridiculously insane
policy like for example this policy out
of Oregon a county in Oregon is now
exempting non-white people from a new
order that requires face masks be worn
in public okay so why to prevent racial
profiling to prevent racial profiling
Lincoln County health officials
announced last week all residents must
wear face coverings when in public
places in which they are likely to come
within six feet of another person who's
not from their own household but people
of color do not have to follow the new
rule if they have heightened concerns
about racial profiling and harassment
over wearing masks
officials said according to the New York
Post ok first of all this is blatantly
illegal you cannot have a law that
applies to white people but not black
people second if you want to kill black
people is a great way to do it honestly
look if you want black people put at
higher risk of Copan 19 tell all of them
not to wear masks because aberrational
profiling masks are protective if
they're not protective you are leaving
then why are we wearing them that's the
whole purpose of them this is insane
speaking of bad policy Nancy Pelosi is
trying to push her pregnant you on
police reform and because of her white
wall credentials she's suggesting that
the GOP that disagrees with her he's
trying to Reimer der George Floyd or get
away with the murder of George Floyd
it's a hell of a thing to say
I've had a bill being pushed by the GOP
co-sponsor my senator Tim Scott the
black Republican senator from South
Carolina Nancy Pelosi here she is what
something to happen they're gonna have
to face the realities of police
brutality the rally of the need for
justice and policing and in recognition
that there are many many good people and
law enforcement but not all and that we
have to address those concerns so when
they admit that and and have some
suggestions that are worthy of
consideration but so far they were
trying to get away with murder actually
the more
Jewellers boys so where is all of this
coming from well you met Jonathan Chait
mentions the book white fragility by
Robins Angeles topping the bestseller
lists the basic idea of the book is that
if you are white you are racist and
because you are white and because you
are racist it is your responsibility to
tear down the system the book is insane
it's insane it's a cultish piece of
nonsense it truly is it is not an
argument about changes that need to be
made to the structure it is basically
you must listen to Robyn D'Angelo and
pay her as a diversity trainer in order
for your thetans to be removed right all
of your unspoken sins that you haven't
even committed you have committed by
dint of your white skin and that can
only be you can only be cleansed of your
thetans if you listen to Robyn D'Angelo
I mean the book is such garbage that
there are many people who again are on
the Left or looking at this and going
this is insane
like fully insane Jesse single and Katie
Herzog have a podcast that is again a
podcast from the left in which they talk
at length about Robyn D'Angelo's book
white fragility and their take is
exactly right
this book is utterly crazy it is the
number one best-selling book in America
she's recently hosted on Jimmy Fallon so
what is in this book I think it's
imperative to talk a little bit about
what's in this book because it's so
popular and because all of your white
walk friends are recommending it to you
if the book is crazy
it's filled with craziness so there are
several central contentions in the book
all of which are utterly nuts okay
they're basically I would say eight
major problems with the book okay eight
categories let's put there's like eight
categories of major problems in the book
first is the historical narrative that
Robyn D'Angelo draws so Robyn D'Angelo
is a crazy person she's a crazy I mean
that's the only way to categorize this
she's a nut she's a full-on nut the way
that she describes it there there are
eight problems in broad strokes one it
is filled with historical nonsense okay
she suggests that the history of America
has not changed for example there's a
direct quote from her book women were
denied the right to vote until 1920 and
black women were denied access to that
right until 1965 no black women were
allowed to vote in 1920 just like all
other women now if you want to talk
about the Voting Rights Act and the
necessity of broadening the capacity for
black women to vote that's okay but you
can't read this book without coming away
with the idea that black women were
legally not allowed to vote in the
United States until 1965 which is not
true she says this this is just an
amazing quote in some ways racism to
adaptations over time are more sinister
and concrete rules such as Jim Crow the
adaptations produced the same outcome
people of color are blocked from moving
forward but have been put in place by a
dominant white society that won't or
can't admit to its beliefs so Jim Crow
was less bad than what we have today
according to Robyn D'Angelo quote there
is a curious satisfaction in the
punishment of black people the smiling
faces of the white crowd picnicking at
lynchings in the past and the satisfied
approval of white people observing mass
incarceration and execution in the
present she's literally comparing people
who attended lynchings in nineteen 1916
with people in 2020 who are watching the
workings of the criminal justice system
which is patently insane she's a crazy
person ok so that's a category number
one and again the historical narrative
matters as I talked about in my book how
to destroy America in three easy steps
if you draw America as thoroughly evil
and never changing well then it is very
easy to talk about destruction of the
system which of course is what she is
talking about which brings you to number
two red big problem number two with
Robins Angeles bug problem number one is
historical nonsense problem number two
is that she basically labels the big
problem all of America systems
she says individualism is very bad
because if you think of yourself as an
individual then you don't actually
understand that you are a member of a
race so thinking of yourself as an
individual is really bad and thinking of
others as individuals is just as bad you
have to think of them as members of race
which again last I checked is actually
the predicate to all avoid superiority
and racism right if you think of people
as members of groups rather than
individuals that is a bad thing that is
a bad thing she says she says crazy
things like this denying that we have
few cross racial relationships by
proclaiming how diverse our community or
workplace is is enacting racism
attributing inequality between whites
and people of color to causes other than
racism is racism meritocracy if you
backed the meritocracy that's racist
if you back objectivity these are things
she says exact objectivity that the idea
of objectivity is racist
okay so ripping on American systems
ripping in American history she also
talks about problem number three she
treats black people as tokens I mean
clearly treats black people as tokens
you're seeing this with that white lady
who's screaming at the black cops and
saying I can talk about racism I'm a
white lady and racism is our problem
treating what black people as tokens is
clearly a Robyn D'Angelo thing right she
says things that are just crazy
she said perfect example quote
I told my fellow white participants this
is it a meeting and if they felt moved
to tears they should please leave the
room I would go with them for support
but I asked they'd not cry in the mixed
group that white women not cry in front
of black people I would go with them for
support they'd not cry in the mixed
group after the discussion I spent the
next hour explaining to a very outraged
white woman why she was asked not to cry
in the presence of people of color there
is a long historical backdrop of black
men being tortured and murdered because
of a white woman's distress we white
people bring these histories with us our
feet our tears trigger the terrorism of
this history particularly for African
Americans she suggested if a white woman
cries in front of a black man the black
man's immediate response to think he's
gonna get lynched she's a crazy person
well he she probably number four she
redefines racism as just whiteness and
whiteness is defined as being white in
American society she uses insane
examples of racism that are clearly not
racist right so she uses an example of
racism that's clearly not racist you're
at a store your child points out a black
person and says hey mommy a black guy
and you say to your kid Shh and the
review says cuz you're afraid your kid
is embarrassing the black eye she says
that that is you silencing the racial
discussion with your four-year-old at a
grocery store because you're a bad bad
racist hey that's another problem with
her book she also I mean it's just it's
cultish crap it's just cultish crap she
said this is a direct quote from her
book how can I say that if you're white
your opinions on racism are most likely
ignorant when I don't even know you I
can say so because nothing in mainstream
US culture gives us the information we
need to have a nuanced understanding of
arguably the most complex and enduring
social dynamic of the last several
hundred years okay so in other words the
only way that you can be disabused of
your of your ignorance is by reading her
book she suggests that if you claim
you're colorblind or that you celebrate
color because you marched in the 60s or
because you marched for particular cause
you can't say that if you say that then
you have taken race off the table this
is a record from a book if racism is not
a topic of discussion between a white
person and a person of color who are
friends this absence of conversation may
indicate a lack of cross racial trust so
if you don't talk with your black friend
about race it's not because you're
friends and you don't feel like talking
about race because you're just having a
good time and your friend doesn't want
to talk about it it's because you're a
racist also though she says in this book
that if you ask a black person about
racism then you are your tokenizing the
black person because it's not the black
person's job to explain race
isn't to you which leaves only one
person who can explain racism to you
Robyn D'Angelo oh this whole thing is
insane
but the main goal of it is to make white
people feel superior for interrupting
the system and for tearing down the
system right white people are
responsible everything is encapsulated
in that one clip at the white lady
screaming the black cops that it is her
job to take care of racism not the black
cops and she has more to say about the
about racism than the black cops do that
perverse attempt to self aggrandizing
expense of the actual country and at the
expense of black people in many cases is
truly horrible for the country but we
are watching it up hayes alrighty I'm
gonna do a deep dive by the way on Robyn
D'Angelo's book this weekend I'll go
through it in detail so stick around for
that also I'm gonna be here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content and I will be back here tomorrow
with much much more coca 19 updates and
all the rest so check us out over at
daily we're calm and subscribe for all
of that I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
produced by Colton Haas executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling assistant director Pavel Vai
douse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Amina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 the media get
caught in another race hoax Chaz chop
goes bicoastal and Jimmy Kimmel gives a
fake apology to the woke mob check it
out on the Michael Nolt show
you
[Music]